i don't know if you know brendan ike he
wrote javascript
in 10 days and that's an interesting
story it makes me wonder
and it was you know famously for many
years considered to be
a pretty crappy programming language
still is perhaps
it's been improving sort of consistently
but
the interesting thing about that guy is
you know he doesn't get any awards you
don't get a nobel prize or feels metal
or
uh a crappy piece of
you know that software code that is
currently the number one programming
language in the world that runs
now is cons increasingly running the
back end of the internet what does he
mean
does he know why everybody uses it
like that would be an interesting thing
was it the right thing
at the right time because like when
stuff like javascript came out
like there was a move from you know
writing c programs and c plus plus
to let's call what they call managed
code frameworks
where you write simple code it might be
interpreted it has
lots of libraries productivity is high
and you don't have to be an expert
so you know java was supposed to solve
all the world's problems it was
complicated
javascript came out you know after a
bunch of other scripting languages
i'm not an expert on it but yeah but was
it the right thing at the right time
or was there something you know clever
because he wasn't the only one
there's a few elements maybe if you
figured out what it was
then you'd get a prize like that
destructive theory
yeah you know babies probably hasn't
defined this
or just needs a good promoter well
i think there was a bunch of blog posts
written about it which is like
wrong is right which is like doing the
crappy thing
fast just like hacking together the
thing that
answers some of the needs and then
iterating over time
listening to developers like listening
to people who actually use the thing
this is something you can do more in
software uh
but the right time like you have to
sense you have to have a good
instinct of when is the right time for
the right tool and make it super simple
and just get it out there the problem is
this is true with hardware this is less
true with software is
this backward compatibility that just
drags behind you as
you know as you try to fix all the
mistakes of the past but the the timing
was good there's something about that it
wasn't accidental
you have to like give yourself over to
the
you have to have this like broad sense
of what's needed now
both scientifically and like the
community
and just like this it was obvious that
uh
there was no the the interesting thing
about javascript
is everything that ran in the browser at
the time like java
and and i think other like scheme other
programming languages
they were all in a separate external
container
and then javascript was literally just
injected into the web page it was the
dumbest possible thing in
running in the same thread as everything
else and
like it was inserted as a comment so
javascript code is inserted as a comment
in the html code and it was i mean it's
there's it's either genius or super dumb
but it's like
right so it has no apparatus for like a
virtual machine and container
it just executed in the framework the
program that's already running and it
was
that's cool and then uh because
something about that accessibility the
ease of its
use uh resulted in then
developers innovating of how to actually
use it i mean i don't even know what to
make of that but it does seem to echo
across
different software like stories of
different software php has the same
story really crappy language
they just took over the world i always
have a joke that
the random length instructions that
variable length instructions that's
always one even though they're obviously
worse
like nobody knows why x86 is arguably
the worst architecture
you know on the planet is one of the
most popular ones
you